[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous ils auront de la mousse
bonsoir
derrière ses allures de gendre idéal
connaissons-nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
connaissons nous vraiment julien courbet
ce célèbre animateur à la dentition
irréprochable au lurette chimie est ce
une ce bel éphèbe qui a plus de manquer
d'owni que les frères bogdanoff je suis
policier
c'est une mauvaise photo explique-t-il
cette passion débordante pour les
fenêtres et autres baies vitrées
[Rires]
pourquoi pourquoi est il le seul à faire
de l'équitation avec des lunettes de
piscine
serait-ce le signe d'une personnalité
borderline
toujours est il que le 3 août 2010 8 la
carrière de celui qui s'appelle en
réalité
frédéric rené courbet sartec le blaze va
tout à coup basculer en rejoignant le
groupe m6 le roi de l'arnaqué se fait
piéger par le petit prince de
l'immobilier du tournage sont toujours
pendants le courage de loin par bva
toujours voilà non ce pas messieurs les
réputations
voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors le rappelle bien évidemment que
l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé
la preuve avec ces images tournées juste
après attention elles font froid dans le
dos fun plainte il ya surtout un grand
chapeau stéphane dota tête ya des tas
d'oiseaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était vraiment la sortie du restaurant
oui bien sûr en tournage à bien sûr mais
je ne conduis pas et vous avez vu
combien de bouteilles la tuque ou pauvre
c'était un tournage éprouvant d'origine
bien vous connecter les visions année
christophe qui est un gros du canton de
la bassée serait-elle due à sa
séparation avec le jim carrey de la
porte de saint-cloud génome et cyril
hanouna et la vue de cette image on
comprend mieux pourquoi le pas qui s'est
laissé pousser la barbe
je ne suis pas du tout dans ses blagues
là aussi c'est pour bomber rapport à mon
salaire quoi l'animateur les prochaines
fois
qui a peur pour son cube le mystère
julien courbet reste entier mais une
chose est sûre pardon le seul homme
capable de présenter un magazine
économique tout en portant des lunettes
isis élus
[Applaudissements]
avantage voilà notre enquête est
maintenant terminée et comme chaque
semaine je vous laisse avec votre
troisième épisode de babouche noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bondé a convaincu menez maps et
pour qui balazs oui c'est le cinquième
producteur écoute on n'a pas le budget
pour benino 5e chroniqueur c'est lourd
daniel mais ce qui est bien avec elle tu
vois ça tu peux faire n'importe qui
kelly b novelli
[Musique]
tout à plat grand tour c'est pour ça tu
vois on va avoir besoin d'elle c'est un
caméléon daniel voir sa fille le prépare
tout
parto parto ça parce que tu vois c'est
bon ça m'a besoin de daniel y en a
besoin de réseau je suis ton père très
bon on a compris daniel du réseau bah
oui faut quelqu'un qui nous ramène des
stars des vraies stars plus d'impact tu
penses à quai 20e bien sûr mon qu'elle
bernard montiel bon tir bien tour
montiel bernal et daniel tu t'en occupes
ok allez viens bernardo
maintenant ça
[Applaudissements]
sa performance d'actrice